kevin malone you're next spit that out
spit okay come on let's go you look cute
today boy
thanks girl so yesterday Dwight found
half a joint in the parking lot which is
unfortunate because as it turns out
Dwight finding drugs is more dangerous
than most people using drugs employees
of this office are very small and
delicate deserve protection from local
pervs better a thousand innocent men are
locked up than one guilty man roam free
I am sick over this thing those people
out there are clearly afraid and that
can't happen
not in my house agreed let me show you
what I've been working on
there are several penises there I love
Phyllis to run her eyes over and I'll
see if we can catch this pervert this is
the last thing that Phyllis needs to see
right now
Dwight look at that one Dwight are those
your pants
that's a Polaroid attention everybody
Dwight has something he would like to
say due to a recent incident involving
Phyllis a man a map and his penis I
think you know what I'm referring to
Michael has authorized me to form an
emergency anti flashing task force
question won't that interfere with your
other task forces answer no because this
is being given priority one this is a
petition for the Business Park to
upgrade their security cameras as well
as install two floodlights in the
parking lot and I know I know what
you're thinking won't that just shed
more light on the penises but that is a
risk we have to take Pam you can draw
kind of why don't you work with phallus
on drawing a picture of the exposure
that I can post around the community
palace Phyllis sorry I've got penises on
the brain
I didn't know that you were at a party
on Saturday night I go to a lot of
parties okay I'm gonna need to search
your car give me your keys I am NOT
giving you my keys don't make me do this
the hard way what's the hard way I go
down to the police station on my lunch
break
I tell a police officer I know several
what I suspect you may have in your car
he requests a hearing from a judge and
obtains a search warrant once he has
said warrant he will drive over here and
make you give him the keys to your car
and you will have to obey Him yeah let's
do it that way right is he bugging you
Dwight dude you gotta take a chill pill
man it was one joint in the parking lot
you know you're you're totally harshing
the office Mel oh I can't stop this
investigation it is my job whoa you are
a volunteer I volunteered for this job
and that's not the same it is my duty
volunteered to investigate the crime
scene I have six more interviews to go
and then I will reveal what I know narc
if you're attempting to compliment me
then you have done a very good job
I wasn't attempting to compliment you
well you have both how's being a narc is
one of the hardest jobs that you can
have okay and I am very proud of you
just cool it cool it Dwight please God
dude where's my office I totally lost it
cuz I was half-baked smoking doobies
Doobie Brothers I was smoking doobies
with my brothers
peace out Seacrest well your office is
behind you
thanks munchies
who wants some Montrese I don't think
Michael's ever done drugs I don't know
if anyone's ever offered him any Oscar
visited Mexico when he was five to
attend his great-grandmother's funeral
what does that mean to a United States
law enforcement officer he's a potential
drug mule have you ever taken any
illegal drugs no I have not do you think
it's possible that maybe you could have
had some drugs in your system without
you knowing about it what are you
implying have
pooped a balloon okay I'm done with this
you sure left in a hurry I don't want to
blow this this is what all good law
enforcement officers dream of the chance
to solve an actual crime do you know
what this is yes it's marijuana how do
you know that it's labeled chant that is
Northern Lights cannabis indica no it's
marijuana
I'm just saying that you can't be sure
that it wasn't you that's ridiculous of
course it wasn't me
marijuana is a memory loss drugs and
maybe I just don't remember I would
remember well how could you of it just
erased your memory that's not how it
works no how do you know how it works
knock it off okay I'm interviewing yo
you said that I'd be conducting the
interview when I walked in here now
exactly how much pot did you smoke Jim
is in charge of Stanley only in sales
related matters hence the green line
green for money sales get it there is
this yellow zigzag that does give Ryan
the authority to discipline Stanley
great
however in so doing it seeks past your
name hence zagging you and making you
appear weak that's the yellow color
yellow for a cowardly what's the pink
menstrual cycles these are anybody up
here anybody at all they can deal with
this you and me
well there is the emergency disaster
mode for the org chart this gives me
full authority over every single person
in the office
all you have to do is say it I'm just
saying I'll think about it
say it just do it don't think saying do
it five four three two do it give me
control Michael
I promise to give authority back to you
on this crisis is over do it Michael do
it hey this office needs a strong man
Sam Nozik
all right well deal with this or so Oh
what's this
that has been merit Jim Halpert
tardiness oh I love it already you got
to learn Jim you're a second-in-command
but that does not put you above the law
oh I understand and I also have lots of
questions like what does it demerit mean
let's put it this way you do not want to
receive three of those lay it on me
three demerits and you'll receive a
citation now that sounds serious
oh it is serious five citations and
you're looking at a violation four of
those and you'll receive a verbal
warning keep it up and you're looking at
a written warning
two of those that'll land you in a world
of hurt in the form of a disciplinary
review written up by me and placed on
the desk of my immediate superior which
would be me that is correct
okay I want to copy on my desk by the
end of the day or you will receive a
full desaturation what's a dissident
what's that oh you don't want to know
so do you want to see it or not no like
like crowds oh my god you're like
agoraphobic agoraphobic yeah really yeah
you would rather sit under couch and
watch a Phillies game then go out to a
movie with your awesome girls absolutely
correct
later Jem calves have a good weekend now
bye okay so this is to happen you're
gonna suck it up there we go and we're
gonna go to dinner okay
hey please call security every day for
eight years I have brought pepper spray
into this office to protect myself and
my fellow employees and every day for
eight years people have laughed at me
well who's laughing now
I graduated from anger management the
same way I graduated from Cornell on
time now I'm back got a second chance
and I'm not gonna blow it so look out -
under Mifflin
I mean look out in a fun way you know
not like I'm gonna hurt you hey guys
guess who's back no need to thank me I'm
not a hero I am a mere defender of the
office you know who's a real hero hero
from heroes
you